foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you build
wealthy work you love and create
great relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the phone
number eight eight two five five two two
five I'm Kim Coleman joined by my
colleague the fabulous
Rachel Cruz ladies and gentlemen thank
you Ken yeah it's very nice feels right
yeah the adjective yeah I'll take uh you
know I feel like mailing it in and just
going I'm Ken Coleman with Rachel Cruz
come on let's bring something that's
what some do I'm supposedly the work guy
right do great work I feel like you need
a great introduction so yep in my work
it's not flattery it's just me trying to
bring it on this Friday thank you Ken
finishing well we need to finish well
the fabulous we got incoming three hours
ahead of us mother of three
wife to Winston she is Rachel Cruz
multiple best-selling author she's here
to take your money questions I'll take
your questions about work uh getting
that income up and uh everything in
between so let's get right to it Abby
joins us to kick things off in Salt Lake
City Utah Abby how can we help
hi guys thanks for having me on super
grateful well we're grateful to talk to
you what's happening
my husband and I just finished Financial
Peace University through our church very
blessed for that we're 27 and 28. wow
good for you guys we just got into our
careers and we're making a lot more
money than we're used to and we have
great guidance from y'all great and
we've always tied that 10 and since we
got our careers and started budgeting we
put another 10 into charity so we're
giving 20 so my question is we're
technically on baby step two sixteen
thousand dollars away from finishing our
student loan debt and being completely
debt free nice we're about two to three
months out and my question is are we
jumping the gun by over giving
um
no
I wouldn't say so Abby I think which you
have to realize and people listening
right now you know especially when
you're in that baby steps you know one
through three
um we still encourage giving we talk
about giving you know 10 and the way
we've kind of viewed it is you're
practicing that giving muscle which I
think is very important to just the
character of who you are through this
process so you are making it a habit of
living with an open hand which is really
important so you're doing that and then
as much focus and intensity we can put
towards paying off debt getting an
emergency fund built and once our house
is in order
then you're able to give radically above
all of that and especially when you get
to baby step seven you know you're just
investing at that point and no debt at
all including the house payment is done
then you're really really able to give
so
um so what I would say to you is you
know understanding that yeah giving is
is very crucial
but when you give any amount of money
right that is quote unquote taking away
from progress and baby steps two and
three
um so we want to have that balance if
you will because we want you to give a
little until you can give a lot and so
but what I would say for you guys is
also I'm not legalistic about the
subject at all because if you feel
compelled and there's a conviction you
know on you guys that are like no no
this is what we're supposed to be doing
with our money then do it I'm not going
to sit here on the other side of a radio
show you know or a radio call and tell
you not to do that
um but what we teach just so you so you
hear that Abby is just that full
philosophy of giving something
until you're able to give a whole lot
more because you're out of debt and your
house is taken care of with an emergency
fund
so the fact that you guys are yeah
charity yeah two to three months away do
you know what I mean like yeah you're
you guys are fine you're fine I don't
want to be legalistic about it but I
also don't want people to hear on the
other side oh my gosh I gotta give away
half my income in order to be a you know
a good person or whatever the thing may
be right so that giving element is
really important
um and it can be practiced so much
greater and magnitude when you have
these other things taken care of
gotcha how's that feel makes sense
yes what are you guys doing by the way
you said you got your careers lined up
what are you guys doing
yeah so we were restaurant servers got
through school with some student debt
and everything worked that whole time
and now he's an engineer and I'm in
Human Resources nice for you guys what's
your Collective uh take home excuse me
just uh
yeah 125 gross wow that's great and you
said uh 16 000 left in baby step two is
that right
nice so how soon do you think you're
gonna pay that off
uh it looks about two months wow getting
after it I know Abby that's so great
yeah and I think you got I mean your
heart is in the exact right place and
when you're doing great yeah I mean I'm
not I wouldn't I wouldn't steer you one
way or the other and hate to be
ambiguous about it but
um yeah I think I think the principle
that you stand on right is one of an
open hand yeah generosity is and that's
so important and so for most people
they're not doing that at all and we
encourage that but then also you you
know scripture is very clear that you
want to take care of your whole
household first or you're worse than an
unbeliever too so you don't want to get
behind on anything and and again that
progress you can make when you're out of
debt and you have an emergency fund in
place the margin you have I think from a
mental standpoint and a financial
standpoint is just so much greater to
give even more yep and you guys got a
plan you're two months away from being
completely debt free and then you're
going to fill up baby step three and
that emergency fund pretty quickly is my
guess uh and the whole time the spirit
of giving it's just you are the person
you are you know uh when you're in debt
when you're out of debt and and money
reveals a lot of characters so I gotta
ask you this as a young couple how's the
budgeting process for you guys in this
in this I mean you guys you guys got a
lot of uh chemistry how's that gone for
you young married couple getting out of
debt and using the budget
and it's
it's been I'm the financial mind he's
the free spirit we've really come to to
grow through and it came in at the
perfect time in our lives I mean there
are late 20s here that's great are you
using every dollar
uh we do uh-huh I was wondering because
you just came through fbu so that's
really really cool I got to ask you this
because I want to talk about you've got
a free webinar coming up that I think is
amazing and I want you to talk about it
but but I just want real quickly Abby
what has it done for you guys how has
every dollar helped you in this process
yes
categories and it's taken a lot of the
guesswork out
so we haven't had to you know do all
that extra mind wrenching on what where
things should be it makes it automated
so we've really enjoyed it that's
awesome being able to sit down and see
that well cool well thanks for sharing
that Rachel I want to talk about this is
this a great opportunity uh to find out
the details on Rachel's webinar
everydollar.com budgeting but tell folks
what you're going to be doing and why
they need to be attending this yes we
just had one earlier this week and it
went really well I think it was close to
2 000 people showing up yeah oh it's
great and yeah and I think it's one of
these
um really important things that I I feel
really that's really important to your
financial journey is understanding how
where your money's going and that it's a
tool to be used how do you use it most
efficiently and when you have a plan for
it then you're able to to stretch those
dollars so when's the next one so you
can go to everydollar.com budgeting Jade
has one coming up next and then I'm
after her and then George has I think
one or two in September all the details
by the way these are free webinars right
is that correct yes absolutely so it's
free free listen folks and you're gonna
have Rachel Jade warshaw walking you
through these all the details go to
everydollar.com
[Music]
budgetingeverydollar.com budgeting and
get up into this webinar Game Changer
all right don't move we gotta take a
quick break Rachel's back I'm back this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
the conversation here on the Ramsey show
it's a conversation about your life your
money
your work and your relationships let's
get right back to the phones oh I am Ken
Coleman she is Rachel Cruz we are here
for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right to the phones we go Jimmy
is with us now in Chicago Jimmy how can
we help
hey how are you I'm super excited to be
on the show great uh thank you so much
for having me
um I have a really loaded question
um I like loaded questions that's very
exciting Ken is ready I've been a lot to
explain here so
um my wife and I listen to the entry
leadership podcast every day
um on our way to the gym and we took the
Financial Peace University this past
spring uh as a couple
um we are debt free
um pay to all of our student loans and
everything from uh previous uh sale of
our house uh last year
um this year
um we moved in actually bought a 15-year
loan new home 10 down uh less than 15 of
our net we also have a duplex uh which
was my wife's primary residency before
we uh were married uh it's fully rented
will be paid off in about five years
um we also have a three-month emergency
fund we started tithing recently uh it
all feels really really good uh this
year our gross income is pacing for
about 385k uh total as a couple right uh
last year we took in about 400 K my
wife's a professional sales leader I'm a
pre-sales engineer for an I.T Solutions
company the reason why I'm calling is
because I'm at a crossroad I have a
passion for technology really good at
what I do and I have a side hustle for
roughly on and off for about 16 years uh
last year I put a lot more effort into
the business and made a gross income
last year of 60k uh this year I'm pacing
to make about 120k and I have about 23
customers that I you know manage
websites for and do their it work I
recently brought in two deals this year
that will gross forty two thousand
dollars and I'm deciding to use that
money to pay off twenty four thousand
dollars in business that majority of it
is my truck that's in the business name
um and then just to kind of get into
some of the the details before I get to
my question
um my technology company also started a
video blog brand focusing pool and
billiards and I'm so feel like I'm so
stretched thin because I get calls you
know and requests constantly from my
side house will customers to my
full-time role
um you know I can't give 100 of my
full-time job plus my side household
it's killing my momentum how much are
you making right now in your day job
my day job um it's it's roughly between
because I I'm part commission part uh
salary so it's roughly between 200 to
240.
and you guys have the only debt you have
is this business truck
yes and the rental
I am the rental yes how much do you have
how much do you owe on the rental
uh the rental is about 140k
what's it worth and it's
um it's worth about three roughly about
300 380.
do you guys like it do you like the
rental property or is it a headache we
do we do like it um I I love renovating
properties
um it I I have had about three homes
that I renovated in the past and I love
doing it right now with our renters it's
we're bringing in about 3 800 which
we're doubling up on the mortgage to get
it paid off in about five years
did you already renovate it
yes we did
yeah uh I I think I know what your
question is
uh so go ahead and hit me with it I
think I I think I know what the question
is what is the question yeah so I mean
my job is stable it's I have an upper
trajectory for the company you know like
I can move into a director role and
whatnot and make even more money over
the years my wife and I recently got
married we're planning on sending a
family and I'm a bit anxious to taking
the plunge and taking my company full
time
um I you know I do have a good friend
who owns a five million dollar a year it
company he'll be hopefully retiring soon
and I'm wondering do I negotiating owner
financing buyout um during that time you
know if you're in my shoes what you do
what would you do would you like slow
down first thing is slow down like you
you slow down I mean you're you you got
a lot going on right now because
whatever this this Billiards blog thing
that's kind of like an offshoot of your
side hustle did I understand that
correctly
it is yeah we're actually in the in the
process of building an app that's going
to help to build your community out
which should bring in some ad revenue
and right but you're maxed out right now
you're already maxed out and stressed
out I'm stressed out listening to you
describe everything too and and by the
way I don't say that critically I go man
you're a high value okay yeah I love
that okay but here's the thing now
you're talking about buying somebody
else's tech company and so you asked me
what would you do Ken so I'm going to
answer it that way I would not be
entertaining any kind of move to buy
someone else's tech company when you've
built your own tech company from the
ground and you're projecting this year
to do half of what you're making in your
day job and you're talking about this
Billiards thing and I wouldn't I
wouldn't buy anybody else's company and
I sure as heck wouldn't Finance it so I
would not even entertain it it would if
somebody brought to me I went
yeah I'd rather work for me and I'm
certainly not going to buy something
from somebody else I think you're
already at a place where financially I'd
say you may be six months away at Max
to moving full-time into your current
gig it's not like you're taking a huge
pay cut you're already a place now where
you've got to choose
and it's going to start affecting you
physically mentally uh it could affect
your day job your wife's making good
money I think you're pretty darn close
to making the move
yeah Jimmy if you went full time if you
like had a dream world where you weren't
doing your day job
how many more like have you have you
projected it out that you could take on
x amount of clients that are that are
realistic that you could actually get
what that income comes like have you run
those numbers because I bet the way
you're the way you function and the way
you think in my heads you're going to
get back up to 200. I would think yeah I
I agree there's a small town that I I
have about four or five customers
literally in that town and if I expand
out to much larger companies out there
um I can easily double that yeah um and
this is all with the Assumption Jimmy
that you enjoy the side hustle more than
your day job correct
oh I love it yeah I love solution
selling yeah yeah that's what I'm good
at all right so Jimmy here's what I
would do I'm not telling you to do this
so I want you to hear me stipulate this
is what I would do since you love
renovating houses and you've already
renovated this duplex I go ahead and
take the cash I'd get rid of it a duplex
for me is not a long-term hold I know
you're getting good rent on it I know
you're five years away from paying out
but this is what I would do so at this
time of transition in my life where I
want to go all in and work for me I'd
sell the duplex I'd pay off the truck
the business loan on the truck you don't
need that so I wouldn't go full time
until you paid off the truck because I
don't want you moving into this side
hustle which becomes your full-time gig
with any debt uh so that's what I would
do I'd cash out and and I'd get stable
on my uh my new dream job which is
working for me and then over time maybe
you buy something cash and keep
renovating and flipping that's what I
would do I don't think you have to do
that yeah I would clean things up right
now because I just feel this
I'll tell you what I would do Jimmy
here's what baby maybe a little
different okay I like options yes I know
here's my here's mine because I one
issue
she had this before we no no it's not
hers it's yours it's it's ours hours
yeah yeah okay well so Jimmy this is
what I would do
you're gonna have it paid off in five
years and and it's not a headache of a
property for you guys right so no it
doesn't so for me if I were you I would
stay in your current job making what
you're making is you're making insane
money doing both I would stay in it for
you know I I mean maybe next spring
start to transition out but I would just
make as much money as possible right now
because you're really good at that pay
off that truck start paying down the
mortgage like you're saying and then
when you jump from your full-time job to
your side hustle which I think can
become really big I think you guys could
pay off that duplex in three years keep
it around let it appreciate uh because I
think you guys have the margin to be
able to do that but I do know there is
something to be said of oh my gosh you
could get out of it like what Ken is
saying pay off everything you have a lot
of options then maybe even to jump from
the site from the full-time job to the
CR to the side hustle even faster right
by just having that extra pad of cash in
the bank and then if you guys want to go
get into real estate State you can so
yeah I think you're fine either way
um I like that I don't hate the duplex
by the way Rachel Jimmy I don't hate the
duplex
but I'm having fun with it but my point
is I wouldn't hold on to a duplex I'd
take the profit off the dude yeah
totally give me give me some cushion and
then get into a house and some other
real estate because you love flipping
that's what I heard Jimmy you like the
rest at least the restoration piece so
it might have sentimental value I like
Rachel's idea as well I think you got
great options but I'll tell you this
don't go full time for yourself until
you pay that truck loan off yes that's
good and then I'd start to make the move
pretty quick I think if you hold on for
three four five six more months dude you
might burn out
you know you need a nap that's what you
need you're doing a lot of work I'm
proud of you thanks for the call she's
Rachel Cruz I'm Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsey Show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
um
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Cole and I'm joined by my colleague The
Fabulous fantastic Rachel Cruz we're
here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five today's question of the day is
sponsored by our good friends over at
neighborly they're your hub for home
services and otherwise in other words
they keep Ken and Stacy Coleman married
because I can't do anything around the
house very different than Winston Cruz
the love of your life he's handy I'm not
he is I told him he needs to like start
like a like the modern renaissance
renaissance man site because I'm like I
got an idea for this there's a lot of
he's gonna hate me for what I'm about to
say Winston I apologize
I think he needs to start making some
cameos on your Instagram page with some
quick fixes that all those ladies
and they show it to the Ken Coleman's of
the world hey you can do this look at
this Rachel's husband said you can do
this in two minutes yeah he'd be a
sensation between like distilled water
and regular water and batteries like all
this stuff I don't know any of that so
you already learned something me neither
somebody we should okay keep going but
neighborly you poor ladies out there who
are married to Guys Like Me neighborly's
here for you uh whether it's a simple
repair a whole list of Home Improvements
Mr handyman's experienced professionals
are here to make your homework for you
and make your marriage much more that's
not even the talking points that's just
my point of view visit neighborly.com to
find expert home service providers
including a locally operated Mr Handyman
near you so today's question comes from
Mary in Florida my boyfriend and I have
been dating for eight years and I just
introduced him to you and your seven
baby steps he is on baby step one and
I'm continuing to invest my 15 and
working I'm paying off my mortgage we
are 53 years old live in separate homes
and I'm very nervous about moving in and
or getting married to him because we
think about money so differently I
always think what if and he always has
the mindset and approach so things will
just work out
I would appreciate any advice
suggestions or your perspective you
might any perspective you might have all
right I I before you get into the money
I I I I gotta jump in here dating for
eight years and you're 53
come on it's time to commit paint or get
off the ladder is that the old saying
poop get off the pot that's one uh put a
ring on it uh why buy the cow when you
get the milk for free I mean I can keep
going I mean this is a situation here
eight years
53 they live in separate houses yeah we
got we gotta wrap this thing up soon for
sure
as you take a sip what do you think here
as a woman wouldn't you want the guy to
go dude get your financial life in order
commit to me man uh what are you
thinking well I would I would give him a
little Grace I mean just well not very
nice not in the relationship but the
money aspect because here's the deal he
may not
know how to handle his money well right
and sure I guess at a certain age you
would expect people to be like okay hey
I'm gonna be proactive and look into
this but some people aren't and some of
you listening are in your 50s and you're
just discovering us for the first time
right so I would give him a little Grace
now if he is
very you know if there's a lot of
conflict around it if he's like a no-go
on any of this if he's gonna be racking
up debt and you're trying to stay out of
debt like if there are values in place
that are conflicting then yes you need
to know if you move forward in a
marriage that is a major issue that is a
major issue but for him he may just be
like oh I don't know and then you know
hears and it's like okay cool I can I
can kind of get on board that's great
like he made I think this guy's a goal
he may not be as enthusiastic about it
as but I think that's okay too because
there's a lot of couples out there yeah
that do our plan where one is like so on
board and so hardcore and all of it and
the other one's like yeah I'm mad at the
advice and I'll do some of it but I'm
not gonna be like well that's a good
point you know all in it 24 7 like some
are so I think there's a balance here he
feels like the free spirit you feel like
the nerd but the biggest thing is just
your values around money are you guys on
the same page around that and working
together as a team like all of that
needs to be conversations in my opinion
with a lot of conversations about other
things in life too I think Mary and the
boyfriend ought to come down uh come
down to see you and Dr John deloney for
the old money and marriage event October
19 to 21. do you have to be married to
come to that
uh I mean I don't think we would like
kick you out if you want it's not like
you're gonna check ideas at the door no
we're not bring your marriage
certificate or you don't get entry what
he said yesterday that it'd be good for
like pre-marital stuff too perfect there
you go yeah so they're just looking out
for the people but yes it uh that
because that's about getting on the same
page oh yeah yeah money and marriage
it's why we call it that you know pretty
good October 19 to 21 all the details by
the way ramseysolutions.com events and
uh money and marriage so that's uh
that's coming up in October that'll be
fun I won't be there I'll be watching
college football that time uh I'm not on
the dot enjoy enjoy
I'm not grateful
pictures with my elbow deep and some
chips and salsa so I'll keep going over
there you and John helping them come you
guys up on the hill very good my team's
winning
I don't know is that what you say you
know what Tennessee you don't say
anything I was thinking of all the SEC
like you better be glad Dave ain't
watching today you just said roll Tide
he'd have a heart attack I know why did
I say that I don't know if what is in me
we better move on the rebels let's go to
Ocala Florida where Edgar is waiting
Edgar how can we help
sure what's up
yes so my wife and I are on maybe step
two and the only thing we got left is a
stupid car loan and we finally decided
it's time to get rid of it or yeah
okay uh how much you guys I want it
uh 40. you owe 40. oh hold on a second
where's my Tums and how much can you
sell it for
uh according to KBB somewhere along 30
or 33. okay we'll go 33 just to be
optimistic uh how much do you guys make
a year Edgar
um right now I'm making around 55 to 60
in between two jobs but we're getting
pay cuts right now so we don't know
what's gonna happen oh no what's causing
the pay cut
uh new system implemented by our um
Corporation unfortunately new system
implemented
no so basically they do I I'm a mail
carrier and they do mail counts every so
often with the new system we had a pay
cut back in back in March and April and
now there's another account coming in
two weeks so we don't know what's gonna
happen oh boy oh man I'm sorry
um okay so the 60 is that just you or is
that your wife included does she work
that would be just me does she work at
all
and no should this day at home okay
perfect uh yeah way too much car so I
I'm with you on selling it so you're
gonna have to go I would go down to your
local credit union and you're gonna have
to get a loan for the difference so
you'll have to take out that seven you
know seven thousand dollar loan you know
you could even up it to to 10 grand 11
Grand 12 Grand to have some margin there
to buy a car because you have to replace
this car that you're gonna sell and then
that will be the debt that you attack is
that new loan so a twelve thousand
dollar loan is much better than a forty
thousand dollar loan so I think that you
guys are hungry yeah you guys are making
making the right call by selling this
for sure so I would just yeah take a
loan out for the difference with a
little bit more on top of it to get a
beater get a car that's not great that
she hates but you're gonna drive it for
you know six months while you guys work
to pay this off pay off the the you know
eleven thousand dollars or whatever you
end up taking out and uh and then yeah
you'll upgrade over time car wise but
again this is a not not a great car and
that's your only debt is that right
right that would be my only day before
we can taste a little bit of Freedom
yeah that's great yep I would do that do
you have another car I'm assuming your
wife has a car
uh that would be my wife's car the car
that I have personally for work is paid
off for oh okay so it's your wife's car
I see yes do you guys have kids uh
follow-up question because the loan is
with my local credit union because I am
a member and I already talked to them
about it and they said they cannot give
me a personal loan to cover that
difference
okay then I would shop around then I
would go yeah find someone else
um yeah I would go ask go ask around
because
um and maybe even lower that amount and
maybe you guys are a one-car family for
a season too A lot of people do that you
know it's not convenient but but even
you know taking it down to a one-car
family if you have to
yeah absolutely yeah great job you guys
though yeah absolutely thanks for
calling and and that's the stuff that
you know especially when you look at
those numbers
forty thousand dollar loan to a sixty
thousand dollar I mean even possibly
getting a pay cut yeah so you're owing
on a car as much as you're making so
that's the time a hundred percent you're
gonna sell sometimes we tell you if you
can pay it off within 18 months and it's
less than 50 of what you make you know
maybe you can keep the car and put it in
your debt snowball but situation like
this it's an automatic sell gotta get
after it Edgar get after it appreciate
the call you guys are gonna get there
don't give up the best is still coming I
promise all right good stuff there
thanks again for the call she's Rachel
Cruz I'm Ken coma don't move more of
your calls coming up this is the Ramsay
show
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
home buying Market but there's a way you
can get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey show where we help
you win in your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to jump in I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz and we're here for you this
hour hey we've got a lot of new folks
coming in all the time whether it be
podcast uh YouTube Radio however and
wherever you listen to us and we've got
some lingo and we've got you know the
seven baby steps and there's a lot of
details with that and we know there's a
lot of new language if you will new
behaviors that you are listening to and
so we've got an awesome way for you to
get started in this journey if you're
now weighing in and going okay I I want
to learn more about this and you do this
by going to ramseysolutions.com and
click on get started right there on the
website
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
and very quickly with a few questions
we'll get you caught up to where you are
in those baby steps and what resources
that you need as you are listing in to
the conversation and of course we
welcome you to call anytime triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right Justin is up next in Madison
Wisconsin Justin how can we help
yeah thanks for taking my call
um I'm a very flattering job offer to
change companies and
I guess we have some cold feet on the
decision and we want to make sure we're
not making a mistake based on some
impressive salary figures well I can
tell you right now the way you set that
up you've already got a level head so
before you even get into the details
when you say you've got cold feet what
do you have cold feet over what's making
you question this and give us a call
today
well so I mean I've worked for a good
company today it's very stable
um
so I'd be giving up some of that
stability and then we'd also be moving
away from some family for this so and
then you know and then the financial
piece is kind of the piece we look at it
too so we had some impressive salary
figures but it's a higher cost of living
area we'd be taking on additional
mortgage
or possibly considerably more mortgage
to move there and just want to make sure
um you know financially this is a smart
decision I also have a defined pension
with my company today
which is a very nice perk but is also
some golden handcuffs that you know
sometimes you don't you don't want to
leave and limit your options sometimes
all right so let me remove so let's do a
little fun exercise okay
let's remove moving away from family
let's remove uh higher cost of living
including a bigger mortgage and let's
just compare the the new offer the
flattering offer
uh and and let's let's also take away
the the bigger PayPal all right so let's
take the job as the job the new offer
just to the job let's remove all that
other stuff if if that were the case
would this be a no-brainer would you
still be mulling it around what's the
answer now
I've worked in that space before and
it's kind of where my passions are as
far as what you know excited to get up
in the morning except you know you work
all day long and before you know it's
five o'clock and it's time offers just
kind of
versus just grinding it out and watching
the clock you know now you also
mentioned in the in the current job you
mentioned the word stability is there
anything about this new company with the
new job that that doesn't feel stable
familiar with the firm I've worked with
them in the past they're a partner with
my career company so we had a prior
relationship so
um
I think from you know a hiring
perspective they might be you know a
smaller company might be a little bit
more flip into vote
you know terminating people or making
changes
um but I'd also say this company is
pretty stability too as one of the
things I respect about them you look at
their org structure and they have a lot
of 20 30 year employees there they're
very loyal today okay good so the reason
I ask you to walk through that uh is
because what you've done here is you've
now hopefully identified you heard
yourself say that that it's just change
and the Very notion of change sometimes
feels like instability so let's talk
about where you would move to let's talk
about I want Rachel to dive into some of
these numbers so you can feel good about
this where would you be moving to and
what type of house what do you owe in
your current house let's say we made the
move walk us through the financials
sure it's uh Boise Idaho is the
destination
um oh boys it's great
yeah so apparently we owe
um about 150 000 left on our mortgage
today
what's the house what did you sell it
for
uh 750. oh wow Yahtzee good job I like
where this is headed Justin okay so then
um so for a similar caliber house there
you'd probably be talking another two
hundred thousand dollars though in that
market what 8.50
no I'm probably more like 950 or even a
little more okay guys I got you 950 okay
well wait a second does it have to be
the exact same size house
it doesn't but yeah we've taken a trip
out there and based on where the kind of
area we'd like to live and what the home
calibers are that's what we'd be looking
and what are you going to be making in
the new job
um so right now I'm making like 160 to
190 with bonus depending on the Year
this job is probably 300 to 350. okay so
listen when you with the equity in your
home yeah if you go and just say hey
we're going to take all of that Equity
buy a 950 000 house if that's what you
guys choose to do yeah yeah then you
guys only have you know you have a 300
000 mortgage nothing and you're you're
making 300 000 so you guys could pay
this thing off and yeah it's not like
you guys are moving to Southern
California or San Francisco or the Bay
Area or something right I mean this is
this is very doable just and you're a
very cautious person
maybe a little scarcity mindset it at
times I'm not gonna just label you that
but I'm gonna say at times so I want to
be someone that just says numbers wise
there there's nothing like liberal
leaning on it right you're this is very
conservative
numbers very doable a very doable
lifestyle with this change uh if you
guys choose to and just like Ken said
you may not even need you know you may
not want the 950 000 house maybe you
find one for 800 but but even if you do
Justin hear me say if you guys took out
a mortgage for three hundred thousand
three fifty you're still gonna pay it
off you're yeah yeah a better life work
you love with a ladder
uh Boise is a wonderful place to live
uh did we help with this fear what are
you feeling right now as we walk you
through those numbers
that's very helpful I mean I think you
know there's there's various pieces of
it and the financial one is the end of
the one it's like well it could be an
expense Allison you won't even feel it
do you acknowledge that what Rachel just
said if you were to do that you wouldn't
even feel that
no you're right okay because you're
making significantly more and yeah
you'll be you know you'll be doubling
your mortgage you owe 150 now you'll
probably owe 300 but yet you're going to
be making a hundred thousand dollars
more in the process so yeah you're not
being unwise at all in that
um and Justin let me just say even
though you guys have gone there and kind
of scoped out where you want to live I
would even pause on buying and go you
guys go rent somewhere love for six
months to a year kind of settle down and
figure out okay where exactly do we want
to be and then at that point you know
move forward the home buying process
so that you so that part doesn't stress
you out right like the move rent for 12
months yeah
how's that help your safety gland which
is sizable
and we lost it and I think he fainted
I thought I think we hit him with two
with super race she was like I
have that I'm out Justin Justin are you
there Justin I don't know we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna uh we're gonna
get a hold of his wife folks don't be
worried I'm gonna check on him give him
a cold rag maybe a Pepsi no we'll sip on
there with a cracker and I appreciate it
a little little seven up so that's it
thank you that's what I was trying to
get at give him give me ginger ale
please no Justin I think you're I I
really appreciate
the caution but I think this is a
win-win it's a win-win from just the job
standpoint is what Ken kind of filtered
out it's a better job for you you're
gonna enjoy it more uh you are going to
be making more
and it's yeah slight standard living but
also think about you know you know and I
know boys uh Boise is a larger town in
the you know Idaho
area yeah but also you know it's it's
it's probably not that much different
than Madison I mean like I like what you
said I I love you saying go in there for
a year and rent a nice house
settle just chill yeah you think that
neighborhood that you saw is the one you
want to go to well of course you know I
rarely buy the first pair of nice shoes
I look at I like to look around Rachel
doing research I want to walk around in
them see I'm gonna go to this store walk
around in their shoes and I think that's
a really good idea to take your time
you've already got a massive transition
so good and do it do it we like it she's
Rachel Cruz I'm Ken Coleman this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman with the extreme privilege to be
sitting alongside the one the only the
fabulous Rachel Cruz my colleague friend
of years thank you good to see you
Rachel and it's Coleman come on hey oh
she's the only person in the building
that calls me Kenneth Kenneth uh that I
will allow but it just feels right from
you it does great to be with you Friday
as well uh we had it we have already had
a fantastic first hour here we go here
we go here we go Amarillo Texas Allen is
waiting for us there Alan how can we
help
hey guys it's a pleasure to talk to you
you bet
so
I hear all the time
don't finance a rental property
so I have been diligently saving and I'm
about ready to I think pull the trigger
on getting a rental the problem is I
would like to hear you guys opinion on
how to like structure setting out myself
for Success when it comes to
you know doing this as a business how
much money have you got saved
um about
170 000 and what are you looking at
buying
that's that's why I'm calling it
actually all right so I was going to see
sort of do you all recommend something
like multi-family or single family
something that you know multi-families
are cheaper but harder to sell from what
I have noticed online you know how do
you how do you recommend taking next
steps as opposed to uh you know for the
structuring of the deal as opposed to
just the financing side
yeah I mean I think it's I think it's a
great question and real estate is
something that you know we talk about a
lot on this show is just another Avenue
to Building Wealth and I know the you
know one of the best ways that you're
going to just make money in general Alan
because we look at real estate
specifically I should say we within the
Ramsey family the way that I've seen it
always kind of the the viewpoint on it
is that it is it is a long-term play
that you're not gonna you know you're
not gonna be getting rich off of the
rentals that you're getting every month
it really is a it's an equity play uh
it's even a play to say hey we're gonna
keep this for decades and even pass it
on you know maybe to my kids you know so
like there's it's a long-term play is
that what you're kind of is that your
mindset or is this is it more hey I want
to get into something flip it maybe make
some money on it but I'm gonna do it
with cash because there's two ways to do
it not you know neither one's right or
wrong I'm just curious what your mindset
is
well my mindset is I want to buy
something that I can get into and I plan
on holding for a long time now whether
that's TurnKey whether it's for somebody
to move in or I need to fix it up
because I personally like doing that
kind of work myself yeah that would be
the that would be the play but it seems
like should I set up an LLC for a
property should I just do this under my
name like what do you guys recommend on
that front well before we get into that
piece uh do you have any debt
I do not okay
three to six months 20 years what baby
step are you on what got through college
without the I guess uh
I guess that'd be four five and six good
um I'm kind of a mix I guess because is
your primary home paid off Alan
uh yeah because I bought it as a as a
wow really cheap houses yeah what does
what does 170 get you in Amarillo
assuming that you're paying cash
right
um you're starting to get into a market
that is good three two property not in
the best neighborhoods but some that are
you know decent respectable you could
get a duplex in a fine area they're
going to be smaller and usually need
work
um you can you're starting to really
break into the market at that point okay
now what now here's what I'm curious
about where do we go what's the next
level when does it get you into a much
better investment meaning it's not a
sketchy area it's not entry level is it
250 is it 275
give me give me yeah I'd say it's around
250. all right so you're not that far
away from that how much do you make a
year
um my wife and I make about 130 combined
okay
yeah so I mean I can tell you Alan yeah
so like the LLC I think is is is a smart
play especially if you're going to have
multiple properties in the next few
years if you if you guys you know look
at it and say hey we want we want this
to become part of our wealth building
strategy uh then at that point you know
that's yeah I think that's a great
option very easy to do low lift um but I
would say the two best things to
remember Alan is when you're buying
property you make the most money when
you buy meaning if there's any way which
I know are the market right now is just
crazy but sometimes with those types of
properties that you know I mean if there
is foreclosure short sale any way that
you can get a deal which I know is very
hard right now on the market that we're
in but that's going to be your most
that's going to fast forward your jump
start in this Equity process to get as
much Equity as you can at the buy and I
know you know Dave's rule of thumb with
investment was always I think it's
around like trying to get it at 70 of
value and you having cash is going to be
a really that you're going to a that's a
great negotiating tactic that you're
going to have to be able just to pay for
it you don't have to go through
financing and everything and that's
going to look really appealing so again
any any possible way you can get the
deal and then you know I mean my husband
and I when we our very first one we got
at a as a short sale back 10 years ago
and it was a little yeah uh condo and it
was nasty we went in and got new light
fixtures cleaned it up we rented it for
a few years and then we ended up selling
it to help cash flow the build of our
primary home
um and what it went up you know in just
a few years was was great it was awesome
and so we we sold so just it's kind of
that moving at the speed of cash but the
best the best thing that you can do is
get a deal on the front end Alan and
then yeah if you can see hey I can get a
better deal on something that I know I
can fix up and you're able to put some
money into it uh rent it out making sure
that your tenants doing background
checks I mean I go through that process
so that the renters you have are as
quality that you can get is really
important it's just some make it as less
of a headache but also know Alan that
you're you're starting a side business
in a sense I mean the the the myth that
real estate is just passive income is
anything but and so you do want to make
sure that it's going to be worth your
time and effort of what the average rent
is going to bring in versus how much
hassle is going to go in I mean you want
to really kind of play out these
scenarios because it's real life they're
going to be calling you you know at 11
o'clock on a Friday night because you
know something broke or whatever it is
right so uh taking all of that into
consideration I just want you to go in
with um not a Pollyanna view which I
feel like some people do sometimes when
it comes yeah and I think he's very
disciplined so Alan I'm not hanging this
on you but I don't want you to get so
excited to get there you've saved 170.
and I know you can get something I'd
rather you save a little bit more and
get something that's that's that's a
much better bet and that's good yeah and
and to look at your Roi you know what
are you going to get for rent and and
all of that so there's a there's that
math play as well to look at Alan but I
think it's a great and I think I mean
real estate I think isn't is another
great Avenue 10 seconds or less a
building well five seconds duplex yes or
no you like duplexes it's fine first
first starter first start a rental there
it is she's not mad at it I don't know I
got I got judgment problems I need to
get right with duplexes I don't know
what my problem is I'll work on it on
the commercial break we'll be right back
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz and we
are here for you this hour America what
are your money questions
maybe get some work related questions
that could have some money ties to it
relationship issues around money any of
those questions we're here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to St Louis Missouri
Timothy is there Timothy how can we help
how's it going good how are you sir not
too bad
um my question was career related
um right now I make fifty thousand
dollars a year and I am my wife is
pregnant she's new in March
congratulations
oh thank you we've been married since
last March so it was a pretty quick
turnaround first baby on the way some
changes happening in your life Timothy
oh yeah
um so my current job gives me a
three-month Aid paternity leave
um however I know the vice president of
another company and it's a it's a
totally different type of company than
what I'm doing right now but it has the
potential to pay 10 to 15
000 more a year than when I make now but
there's no
eternity leave I would just have to take
my vacation days as my paternity leave
so I'm kind of my life and I are kind of
debating the pros and cons we're on baby
step number two
let me ask uh when if you were to take
this new job and you're going to make 10
to 15 more is that right out of the gate
is that down the line
um I think if I play my cards right I
would be able to make 10 000 more out of
the gate it's a sales job and that would
just be my salary and then okay uh oh
Commission on top of that but my
commission wouldn't be my commission
rate wouldn't be as good as it could be
right off the bat sure of course but
what's the long-term play let's say that
they had all of the uh paternity leave
that your current job has would you be
jumping at this new opportunity for the
long term
right yeah probably I mean my current
boss has kind of
outlined a career path as well it would
just take probably a couple years to get
to like 70 000 a year um if you took the
new job and you use vacation how much
paternity time would you how much time
would you take off I would probably take
a month off I think I could get I could
I could get that how are you going to
get a monster how are you going to get a
month's vacation in a brand new job they
would just um
I think I I mean I may only be able to
get
two weeks but I think I could all right
how much just because I have an end with
the vice president
um and I know a few people who work
there and they they seem really
interested so what if you came home and
told your wife hey
uh I'm only gonna take a week off how
would she handle that
probably not well
three months is nice the three months is
nice and I and we've been door I've been
doordashing quite a bit so that's
because how much debt do you guys have
left
so we I just read Total Money Makeover
last month okay and complete Paradigm
Shift we paid off 1500 since last month
wow great job yeah
um baby chef one was already pretty much
taken care of just for my savings
um so we owe 2 000 left on credit cards
I I plan on having that taken care of
pretty quickly we do have a car 20 000
on the car I have 23 000 in student
loans and then the home is 121 000. okay
um
okay so what I would suggest uh Timothy
I would take the new job
because you're going to be getting a
massive pay increase which is phenomenal
I mean 10 000 more off the bat is a long
term too yep better long term
um we teach people that when you are
actually when you're expecting a baby or
a big life change coming up and this
would be for somebody that's about to
move for a job or you know there's a big
shift happening a medical some of the
medical is coming up and that you can
foresee we will say pause the baby steps
so I actually still want you working the
same intensity that you're working but I
want you guys just piling cash stay
current on all of your debt but I want
you to pile up cash until after March
when your wife comes home baby comes
home everyone is good you're gonna press
play and I would hope by that time uh
you're going to be able to pay off that
you'll pay off the credit card
immediately uh hopefully majority of the
car loan you'll pay off immediately uh
and yeah you'll start working back down
the debt snowball
um but Timothy I mean I'll I'll be
honest I think you know and as a mom on
with three
um you guys are not in a in a financial
situation you haven't set yourselves up
in a financial situation where you can
just you know take off a significant
time of work I think I think spending
some time home is is a is a gift right
especially as a new parent there's a lot
to do so maybe yeah a week week and a
half at that point but Timothy I would I
would I would still be plugging into
that sales job and be making these calls
um because I'm telling you when you are
able to get this debt paid off as
quickly as possible you're actually
gonna you're gonna be a much you're
gonna have more margin I think to be
able to spend time with family take off
when you want I mean like
um and I'm being very uh compassionate
towards your wife because I know that
feeling but I mean again it's a big
debate this whole thing and I think and
I know you are Ken and I'm probably a
little bit more on the moderate side of
that debate than you are so we can have
that because here's the deal this is
ridiculous no I think I think there is
something about the family unit that is
really important in having wait a second
I got three kids I love my family I know
you I didn't take but you do three days
off when my kids were born you didn't
take three days maybe three maybe oh
it's called listen he doesn't have the
margin he doesn't that's what I'm saying
Timothy doesn't did I did I mention that
it's paid at my current work it's not
just time off it is paid I know but
we've told you okay but we've told you
to take the new gig I know I know I
agree with Rachel I would but I will
tell you this I'm gonna bring I'm gonna
shock Rachel right now if your wife
thinks that I'm a raving lunatic with my
position which is possible
then you gotta choose marriage and your
wife and and maybe you stay in the
current job where you get your paid
three months happy wife happy life I'm
not in any way capitulating here I'm
just saying this may be a real thing
here and I don't want to sound like I
have some fun with my position on this
I'll get back to that in a moment but I
want to be PR I want to be practical to
say to my if if you're my friend and I
want you to be my friend Timothy we're
hanging out my back porch I'm going
where's your wife at on this and you can
always get another sales job that's
right that's right and maybe talk to
that VP if he's your friend I go hey I
want this job with you
are you willing to wait until I've taken
my three months and and then I've got
another option I know so I'm trying to
be fair but but I will tell you
Rachel's right she's so much nicer than
me but she's absolutely right
that you shouldn't be taking a month off
right now you need to be working man to
get this debt right everything under
control
I'm I'm having fun with the fact that
this this is a paternity thing that
didn't exist when my kids were born and
I just think dudes go out freaking kill
something drag back take the feedings at
night help your wife serve your wife
like I did I mean I took two a.m
feedings while starting a radio show
okay I did it I'm putting my money where
my mouth is and everybody who knows me
Ramsay knows I'm a Family Guy yes I go
home yes but I think it's ridiculous
that we would choose
to stay home for months at a time over
furthering our career furthering our
ability to provide for the very family
that you want to be with and I'm not
saying that towards my friend Timothy
I'm saying in general yep I think it's a
bit much
the wife a working mom yeah yeah I've
I'm for more time sure
I know so I don't want people you know
what I'm saying oh totally twerking
women deserve more benefits but dudes
you're the dad
it's gonna be okay right I hear you I
just know when you look back though
hundreds of years though no of just the
way the family was run it was an act you
know we everyone was it was an
agricultural type setting the family
worked together they did everything
together there's something about the
family unit that is so simple and while
my mom was nursing the baby dad was out
picking the pumpkins
working back
yeah she had the baby on her back I know
but I'm just saying that family unit
oh my God jeez
it's nice to have the help toughen up
America this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right let's
go to Carol who's joining us in what
sounds like a lovely Place Mountain Home
Arkansas that sounds like a great place
to be Carol you're on the Ramsey Show hi
thanks for taking my call
so what do you do when life keeps
getting in the way of you getting to
baby step one oh no no tell us what's
been happening Carol well my 14 year old
car with 300 000 miles up and gave up
the ghost in February yeah anyway
I I spent all my money on getting
car to get me around and got that done
got my credit card paid off in June
now the car
I've got to have eighteen hundred
dollars worth of work done on it next
week and I have 500 in my emergency fund
do I take my five hundred dollars and
put it towards the 1800 work and put
1300 on the threaded credit card
or do I continue to shave up my until I
get to a thousand dollars make a minimum
payment on the credit card
and and start paying it off that way I
don't know what to do yeah how much do
you make a year Carol
um
fifteen thousand three hundred I'm
retired on Social Security
okay how old are you
65 55 would you say 65 65 okay 65 years
old
um and you have no uh no money to your
name no retirement
of course not it was always going to
happen next year yep yep next year I
yeah so and I finally woke up I was 55
and you know what's the point well Carol
before we keep going on the numbers here
just real quick are you able to work
no
spray in my back so I can stand up about
20 minutes at a time oh my God yeah no
I'm
I'm an old lady no can I tell you
something you don't sound 65 and for all
the stuff going on with you you've got
some spunk and and I think uh that needs
to be called out you you don't sound
like you're you know uh wasting away
I never smoked
[Laughter]
no cigs for Carol Rachel I know never
have all right good for you
uh okay so Carol I mean I'm gonna be
honest the numbers are tough when you're
just living off Social Security to be
able to kind of gain some traction here
well let me but it's
1275 a month I did took your advice and
I mean I have the strictest
thank you
I maybe put away if I don't buy a pop at
McDonald's once a month so I can
probably put by
350 dollars into an emergency fund I
don't have a car payment and I don't
have a house payment okay and I have
about fifteen hundred dollars in in debt
1500 and that's on what
I have two medical bills and a medical
bill and collections okay I pay a
hundred dollars a month on those three
okay
so we got a car issue we got fifteen
hundred dollars in debt and that's it
yeah okay
um
here's what I would Envision Carol this
may be a little bit of a challenge for
you but but the truth is with you just
collecting Social Security and living
off of you know of that there's not
gonna be big swings in your budget
because the income side is just really
not there
um so I'm wondering Carol
for one year
is there something you can do during the
day to make money from home
I don't know if that's a um a virtual
assistant
um I I don't know there's there's many
different options but I just wonder
Carol maybe a customer service job yep
again and I know you're 65 but I want I
want you to be able to be bringing in
more than fifteen thousand dollars a
year
um well I I would have to buy a computer
or a laptop I don't have either one
uh do you have you have yours what are
you calling us on a cell phone or a
Homeland a cell phone okay well I think
you can find an old used Macbook a
Facebook Marketplace or something you
know finding something so I think having
but don't assume that Carol a level of
Technology you may be surprised I don't
want her to assume that she's gonna have
to buy a computer they made depending on
if you get a customer service role or
something like that yeah something yeah
just be open-minded is what we're saying
here but you've got to bring in some
income yeah I mean that's kind of the
bottom line Carol is I think you know it
would be amazing what you could do
working even 30 hours a week yes uh
making 20 22 an hour
how significantly these numbers start to
drop because the good the other great
thing is 1500 bucks and a you know a car
issue
can be fixed rather quickly by just
bringing in some income and so I think
that would be the biggest thing for you
but as far as your car how much how much
could you sell it for
could I sell it for yeah how much is it
worth
I don't know I just got it in February
it was a 19 it's a 99 yeah Grand
Cherokee with 80 000 it had 80 000 miles
on it when I bought it okay yeah I would
be why I would be curious and obviously
it's broken so you'd have to like factor
in the medical but I or I'm sorry the
the repairs
but I wonder if you would be able to to
somehow yeah if it's worth you know how
much did you how much did you buy it for
back in 3 500 3 500 okay
yeah I mean I'm wondering Carol honestly
if you could
I mean I just when I'm putting 1800 into
a 3 500 car feels like you're just kind
of spinning your wheels at that point
yeah
um
so I mean I I you could look to see you
know yeah is there is there another
option out there could you
could you sell it I mean I I I I can't
in good faith tell you to go and fix
your car on a credit card you know we're
never going to tell you to go into debt
so no no I I know and that's I guess the
the main question is do I continue to
take money out of my emergency if I
empty my my emergency phone when
something comes up
or do I put everything on a credit card
till I get my thousand and then start
whittling about credit cards yeah no no
you're taking it out of your emergency
fund your cash flowing as much as
possible that's why it's there in case
of an emergency so instead of continuing
to go deeper in credit card debt use the
cash that's there and I wonder too if
there's something Carol even with the
current card to go get a second opinion
and I wonder if you can you know find
something that it's not going to be a
long-term fix but something to at least
get you to and from you know the store
or what you need around town uh for 500
bucks and then hopefully you're possibly
getting a getting a job here in the next
month and you're gonna be bringing in
some more to to buff up that emergency
fund back at a thousand dollars but
saying currents you know on that Medical
on those medical bills is key but I
would I would cut up the credit card I
wouldn't even let that be an option
and then when that's not even an option
that's when other options start to come
into play where you have to realize okay
if I don't if I can't charge it on a
credit card what do I do yeah I'm gonna
have to get a second opinion I'm gonna
have to look to see is there a cheaper
way to fix this car no
um or Carol I I just want to know what
kind of community you have in Mountain
Home Arkansas are you a part of a church
Community or do you have friends and and
people around you because you're a
you're an awesome lady I can just tell
and this is what community is for
someone might have a car that they're
not using an extra car that you could
use for a while I mean I want you to
have the courage to say I need help and
I know that's not easy what's your
situation there as it relates to
community
Tampa Florida and I just pretty much
hang by myself I don't go to church I
don't have any Community groups I just
Cheryl
Carol listen over here yeah I I really
think the time is now for you to to
catch some community and get out and
meet some people and and life is Big
good people that will help you right now
you can't do this on your own
um and you've got some tough situations
here so I really want to challenge you
in that area but Rachel gave you great
advice please don't go into more debt
that's only going to make the situation
worse so
um hang on the line I want to get you a
free session with one of our financial
coaches that's our gift to you they can
walk through the details with you hang
on the line This is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
talking with you about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships this is the Ramsey
show the phone number to jump in on that
conversation is triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm Ken Coleman
joined by the incomparable fabulously
looking fall today got her fall style
rocking today if you're watching the
Ramsey Show uh the audience is loving it
you're getting comments you're going
with the sleeveless sweater once the
kids go back to school it's like fall
you just go ahead and break out the fall
Summer's over and I'm with you we're
here in fall all right I can't get to
Sweater Weather fast enough that's a
personal conviction Sweater Weather hey
if you're enjoying the show we would
love for you to help us by sharing the
show however you're watching wherever
you're watching subscribing and sharing
helps us get this message of financial
peace taking control of your life out to
lot of people and this is fun Rachel
our fearless leader James Childs uh
sauce in the hallway here during our
last break and this is really fun just
three of the many many reviews we get
that we're asking you to do for us uh
we've got one from New Zealand
I listen to the show every single day
while farming here in New Zealand this
is exciting so good I gotta call my mom
and tell her that I'm a huge deal
finally I've made it I am now global I
you know I'm not uh who's that guy who's
the bald Global he calls himself the who
is that pit bull I'm no Pit Bull a
global Superstar but uh I am I am on a
New Zealand right now somewhere a guy is
hurting sheep and listening to my voice
is very exciting and then we got one
from the UK which is my personal
favorite if I was going to to leave
America you go to I would I would become
a British
do say old chap give me your yes yeah
yeah I love I love the Brits they're
very nice I love riding the tube you
know look at you're such a local I am I
rode the tube everywhere and uh then
we've got one from Paris
and uh so that's nice too so we are all
around the world that's what's so fun
about this YouTube and podcast stuff
it's crazy the world is truly flat so
choose Paris London which one uh I've
never been to Paris oh you haven't no
I'm very surprised by this I know nope
maybe Winston's saving it for a big
anniversary yeah how many years you guys
at uh 14. uh maybe the old 15. maybe the
old 15 maybe the 25 we'll see okay I
think you would like Paris you know why
everybody sits on the sidewalk at these
cafes I know with the chairs facing the
street which is fantastic it's a very
European thing it's a people watching
Extravaganza I love it wonderful because
I'm a people Watcher it's fun for me you
know a lot of fun people watching in
Paris so there you go you gotta save up
your money gotta go dead free folks to
remember that so all right let's get to
the phones Boise Idaho is where Eric
joins us Eric how can we help
Rachel Ken happy Friday to you yes sir
it is how's your Friday
uh it's doing wonderful good
um so late last year I moved to baby
step six and I've been paying extra on
my Mortgage Debt uh then I've been able
to knock five years off the back end so
far got about 225 to go
um I think it's pretty aggressive but
possible I can pay it off in the next
five years
but it's a new stage for me in the
financial Journey so I was hoping you
could help me
learn how to frame my thinking about
other big expenses while trying to pay
off the house now fortunately I don't
have any immediate need but I'd say
there's a pretty high probability my car
is going to die before the mortgage is
gone oh my gosh Eric what am I thinking
is like you know if I satisfied money
for a car the mortgage hangs around
longer but if I don't do that then I'm
gonna have to dip into my emergency fund
what did you say is going to donate an
emergency sorry the car's gonna die your
car I oh my gosh oh dear I don't even
want to know what you thought I thought
I thought it was a I thought you said
like it was a yeah someone in your
family I don't even want to say it
because it's just something
and the kids said oh no and I was like
what's the car
oh it's all it's uh but 2011 there's an
old Chrysler 200.
I don't know it's got so many miles on
it the odometer stuff like six months
ago but dude would you have any money to
buy a car right now buy a new car Eric
I do
um and that's what I'm trying to figure
out and balancing right because to me
like I have an emergency fund right on
the steps like baby step six I'm
throwing everything I can at the house
which has been really fun
um to see like all the time coming off
the back end of it but I also I I know
I'm probably going to need a car and
I'll get something conservative like you
know for my income
um but I I guess
it doesn't seem like buying a car is a
reason to go into your emergency fund
it's not it's not it's not it's not like
your car is going to die you know that
the day if you buy it you know what I
mean do you have no cash outside of your
emergency fund
uh well I mean like retirement accounts
no I say cash so if you look at your
monthly budget
um do you have any kind of margin over
the next two or three months where you
could change your budget up cash flow
buying another car because you said it's
going to be conservative anyway so
what's that number you're gonna buy ten
thousand dollar car twelve thousand what
is it
so I've looked and I think it's under 20
000. okay all right so do you have any
other cash outside of your emergency
fund that you could put if you just paid
the mortgage
of what's owed not extra on it right
just the mortgage oh yeah oh yeah I've
been throwing thousands at the mortgage
everybody so what's the margin
that you could save up each month
towards a new car
2500 bucks
all right so five six months from now
you know you're getting closer and
closer to that what twelve fifteen
thousand dollars would you sell yours
for you think
uh not much
the odometer doesn't even work okay that
sounds a little sketchy who's gonna buy
that card I actually I'd like to see the
Facebook listing for that one
I don't know how many miles it has on it
yeah and I guess it's a little thing for
me I know like it's just if I set that
money aside because it's not an imminent
need like I want to be responsible and
be prepared when the time
does come that the car is no longer
functional and I've put enough money in
it to make it last this long like I'm at
that point where
no more money makes sense you know it's
just the blue book so so Eric the way we
look at baby steps one through three is
that you are intense this is like the
game on scorched Earth it's like we're
just we're doing everything any extra
Penny we can get in the budget it's
going to pay off debt it's going to an
emergency fund and that that's really
where we're focused and then once you're
on baby steps four through seven which
is where you are four through six then
at that point it's intentional which
means you can kind of step off the gas a
little bit breathe have some margin in
your budget to enjoy a vacation save up
for a new car all of it so again yeah
it's saving up to buy a new car will
yeah delay you months on paying off the
house but again we're not trying to be
intense at the house it's just anything
extra that we have we're going to start
putting towards that so I understand
your excitement but I do want to give
you permission to enjoy your life like
you can you can pause and save up do you
or do you have a family or Eric
I've never been blessed with children
but I have the world's greatest wife
what does she say about all this what's
her take
um well I think we're we're on board
like we have these conversations
together yeah
um and this is this is great a great
place to be for us financially compared
to five ten years ago sure but it's just
new so it's kind of like sure Eric I got
you while Rachel was giving you fabulous
advice I was researching used cars for
sale under 20 000 in Boise Idaho you
ready
I got a 2009 Honda Accord EXL 127 000
miles 9 800 all right you don't like
that it's white yeah okay all right I'll
get you how about a gunmetal color 2016
Nissan Altima 79 000 miles 13 500.
uh uh got a 2014 Mazda uh 116 000 miles
twelve nine I'm telling you I'm all over
it Eric dude you got the money on metal
gray so you are it is okay so I
basically need to like stop a little bit
of my Insanity Eric you're not insane
you're disciplined but it's time
yes slow down a little bit get yourself
a good car go on a nice trip with your
wife it's okay you enjoy some of this
life while you're still yeah intentional
about paying off the house we love you
Eric you're gonna be okay buddy get your
car Rachel Cruz good hour thank you
America this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five eight eight
two five five two two five I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Rachel Cruz who is fabulously dressed in
all of her fall colors she is got the
kiddos off to school
she's ready for some SEC football uh
you're ready if you're only listening to
the show today you might want to move
over to the old YouTube feed at some
point because uh the audience members in
the lobby are loving the fog Garb thank
you you know you look familiar actually
thank you fantastic thank you so we are
always having fun together we're ready
to go the obligatory Compliments are out
of the way and now I can do my job uh
Alan joins us now in Dallas Texas Alan
how can we help
hi how you doing today we're having a
blast what's up you're good so question
for you about student loans I have
approximately 225
000 in student loans wow most most of
what essentially all of us from my law
degree
um so with this 225
000 in loans there is the payee
repayment plan
um so essentially after 20 years uh they
forgive whatever's left and then you've
claimed that whatever's on it as in your
taxes you pay the tax liability on that
so I currently pay the interest on the
loan which is roughly 1 225 a month to
keep the principal where it's at so
roughly pay 14 700 a year on that I have
16 and a half years left uh until I
reach the end of that program meaning I
pay
500-ish over the next 20 years worked
out with my advisor that the tax
liability obviously tax code can change
will be around probably eighty thousand
dollars on that
um so coming out to be 322 000
essentially in payments within the next
16 and a half years so I guess my
question is do I is it making more sense
to utilize that plan and have that uh
that that uh I guess let the loan ride
the 20 years where I have a Roth IRA
that I contribute uh is maximum a year
where I can then pull the after it's
been under the principal for 15 for five
years I can pull that out so I'll have
that money for the pay the tax liability
saved already at year 20 where I could
obviously refi my house things like that
but just wondering if it makes more
sense to to pay down the loan as fast as
I can now or to utilize the program and
was kind of interested on your guys's
Thoughts with that
uh hands down
pay it now start paying on it now I
don't you know when you're using words
you know time frames like 20 years 16
years all of it that's a long time Alan
a long time and I know it's a lot of
debt so how much are you making uh as a
lawyer now with this with this fancy law
degree
uh my wife and I bring home around 200
230 a year Perfect all right so Alan if
I were you guys and I woke up in your
shoes I would act like I'm making 80.
thousand dollars and I'd be paying this
thing off in less than two years
and be done and be done Alan be done no
I'm not waiting around on a program the
whole like yeah it's like the pay as you
earn and it's the oh I mean it's all the
stuff you're hearing all this stuff and
that's keeping you guys yeah with
student loans around you're making an
incredible income you have an incredible
amount of debt but I would knock that I
mean I would I would do anything Alan to
to just be done be done I agree and then
and then all that is yours you're not
doing all this math to be like 14 000 an
intro you know I was exhausted listening
to it I mean just be done Alan you guys
are smart people be done and go live
your lives and go be great lawyers and
make great money and drive fancy cars
and do all the fun stuff like go do it
all dead Vision just don't be in the
cycle of waiting around for programs and
trying to figure out the math just get
rid of it Alan what's your income
potential as a lawyer
the type of law you're doing yeah so
it's the uh probably would uh you know
I'm not a not a not in big law so more
of the smaller firms so most likely
gonna pry around that uh me specifically
that income included my wife so she
currently makes as well so probably
going to be around that three or four
hundred thousand most likely just
because I don't have a lifestyle
obviously you mean you mean together I'm
asking you that was a really good lawyer
answer but you didn't answer me what
kind of law do you practice
uh I do uh estate planning uh mostly so
but probably that that's 400 000. yeah
so Alan and I'm gonna go sorry a step
further even not to go off track of what
no that's why I want to make it more
money I think he can make more money my
point is is there's ways for you to make
more money to fast forward what Rachel's
saying I'm in complete agreeing with her
and if you've got really intense I know
you're I know you're funding retirement
and I know your math brain is really
large because you're giving us all this
math and this call even uh so even
telling you to pause retirement probably
is making you cringe but I would I would
pause everything and I and I would live
on nothing for two years and I would
just be throwing everything at this debt
because you guys could have this cleaned
up and then with your income potential
Alan like what you guys are you're gonna
be millionaires like you guys are going
to be doing great if you finally just
say we're gonna be done playing this
math game of figuring out you know what
can I dance around here and let this
know y'all make great money and let that
work for you let your income be the
thing that helps speed up your wealth
building which it is your income is your
largest wealth building tool
um and so I would I would go scorched
Earth Alan you and your wife when I know
Dallas it's a hard City to do that in
it's kind of that southern L.A and and
you know in the lifestyle I agree creep
is there and you guys are probably used
to live in a certain lifestyle with this
money
but man I would freaking buckle down and
just say walk arms and he has a law
degree and his experience and skill set
is an opportunity to print money and I'm
not being crazy about this but you can
make more money and I would be billing
more I would be finding can I do some
freelance legal work what what does a
move up the ladder look like to get to
what you said to get to freedom and this
brings up something that I think is
really important I am
I'm not a doomsday or you know this
Rachel I am concerned about the 40
million plus Americans
that are about ready to get hit with a
reality that's been paused for a while
and that is student loan payments yeah
uh are coming due in October and I think
it's gonna be a lot of pain in this
country
and so we've decided we've decided to
say we're going to jump into this and
we're doing a very important event it is
a free event
it's our student loan debt live stream
Tuesday September 12th 7 PM Central Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Jade warshaw are
going to be talking about how we got
here but more importantly if you're here
and that's student loan debt
is there hope the answer is yes is their
way out the answer is emphatically yes
so we want you to join us it's a free
live stream listen tell your friends
your family members about it if you know
somebody that is feeling the weight the
pressure the stress of those student
loan payments coming due please join us
September 12th it's a Tuesday night 7
P.M Central here's where you get the
details it's free
ramseysolutions.com student loans
ramsaysolutions.com
student loans it's an important night an
important conversation don't miss it
hope is going to be there
ramseysolutions.com student loans we'll
be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your money and your
relationships and in your work I'm Ken
Cohen I'm joined by Rachel Cruz
the phone number to jump in on the
conversation is triple eight eight two
five five two two five
so here's a quick question for the
audience who likes free cash
I hear the hands I hear the hands going
up all over the place
I'm glad you like the free cash because
you've come to the right place you could
win one of our 500 weekly prizes or the
grand prize of three thousand dollars if
you want to increase your chances all
you have to do is enter daily at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway so that's
ramseysolutions.com giveaway you can
also get our best-selling books like The
Total Money Makeover from paycheck to
purpose and own your pass change your
future for as low as just twelve dollars
and you can pre-order our colleague Dr
John deloney's brand new book building a
non-anxious life where you can learn the
six daily choices to break free from
anxiety and when you pre-order that now
for just 20 bucks you get 75 in free
bonus items and then our popular all uh
let's see questions for humans
conversation cars are on sale for twelve
dollars so you can see here we got a lot
of discounts great deals in August
and while you're there getting great
deals you're signing up to win cash so
that's kind of fun so all you got to do
is shop the sale today and enter to win
daily at ramseysolutions.com giveaway or
ramseysolutions.com
store so there you go all right let's
get to the phones Julie joins us now oh
Green Bay Wisconsin the Packers the
frozen tundra of Lambeau Field do you
know what any of that means at all
nothing the Packers same buffet yes all
right but it's my favorite kin you know
when you host with Ken and a city comes
up he's like oh
the Empire State of Mind New York I
gotta get a little excited I like the
boys play in Dallas and right I like the
references we got Dallas coming up next
he pronounces them right like an old man
thank you very much there it is all
right Green Bay Wisconsin hey you know
what I can't help myself Julie are you a
boy let's get Julian let's get Julia are
you a Packers fan Julie
hi Rachel and Ken
um I guess I have to be because I live
in Wisconsin right right I know I
actually live a little south of Green
Bay but um right they give us a general
area and so I got a little excited I
could tell Julie that you could care
less whether the Packers win or lose it
doesn't matter I don't think they want
to spell gosh so oh you're in Oshkosh
yes is that right the Oshkosh clothing
brand is from Oshkosh Wisconsin yeah
yeah
Julie I'm so glad you called today Julie
Rachel knows this with no you made my
day because I'm gonna go home and drop
that in the conversation tonight with my
wife I'm gonna be like did you know that
the Oshkosh little brand we buy for kids
because it's from Oshkosh Wisconsin is
it an OshKosh am I saying gosh is that
right that was the commercial okay okay
this is the name of the clothing that's
it okay see you get you get financial
wisdom you get work advice you get
relationship advice and you get the uh
little trivia fact that could help you
out at the local bar yep never know
there you go all right Julie Julie we're
here how can we help you thank you for
helping wasted your time oh no problem
it's fun to talk about Wisconsin yes
um so I I am finally getting my divorce
uh finally next week oh gosh
um it's been a long time coming yeah and
I think we're gonna we're just both
ready to be done
um the lawyer split everything and you
know we were very amicable people so I
just
kind of want to just run it by from
Ramsay folks here what to do with my
settlement
so I'm on baby step two
um I've paid off since the spring I
started with Ramsay and I did take a
um course uh
financial piece yeah thank you and I've
paid off about ten thousand dollars good
for you Julie
yeah and I had been starting on it
before I found Ramsay so it just kind of
like energized me and made me feel like
I could really
live how I want to live instead of kind
of living the normal American Life
jewelry right that's awesome yeah yeah
so
um I only have about a little over five
thousand dollars left instead good for
you I will be getting a cash settlement
of just over thirty thousand dollars so
that was
complete my stuff two and three and I'd
have just a little bit extra but then
I'm getting a 401k of about 70 000 and I
saw it one time
um
someone else had called and uh
they were going to be cashing that
because with the quadro
I wouldn't get the extra penalty and I
guess I'm just trying to figure out I
right now I'm renting so what I'm
looking at is
possibly using that for a down payment
on for a house or condo whatever I end
up finding so
yeah yeah I mean I think that could be
for sure great option yeah I don't the
idea of keeping 401ks around with
employers of x's and all of that is not
a great option and yes you know the 10
penalty that you usually would pay
before 59 and a half during during
divorce settlements I'm pretty confident
you're exactly right I think you can
cash out without penalty
um do you have any retirement savings
I have a pension
um that I'll get about 400 maybe a month
okay
um if I wait till like 65 and then I
also have over a hundred thousand
dollars in a 401 for you I just switched
it to a Ross score so good good for you
what is your income
yeah what's that what is your income
uh my income right now is about ninety
thousand dollars a year fantastic Julie
Julie can I just say like the everything
you know in your situation not just the
math and the numbers but just even your
attitude Julie through all this um is is
such on the encouraging positive end you
have a lot of momentum positive momentum
your way through like a really sad
um situation so how long was the the
whole divorce
um how long did all that take because
you said we're finally done with it
well the once I went to a lawyer it went
quickly we were going to do you know uh
to our own divorce but it's just so hard
uh I think dividing stuff up and knowing
legally what all the rules are and stuff
sure I felt it was just worth it to do
that yeah yeah so
um yeah so that worked out uh really
well
um
so um I think
go ahead I'm just gonna say I think
um
part of my situation is that I'm I'm
actually 54 years old and
really part of all this was because I
need to know I need to buckle down look
at retirement I want to enjoy myself in
retirement
um and not feel like I have to live
you know
day by day and worry about money and to
enjoy myself yeah yeah you don't you are
in really good shape Rachel I would love
for her to visit and uh with with maybe
multiple smartvestor Pros in her area
just to get a second opinion on that
401k what would be the best to do with
it because you're gonna have baby step
three taken care of yeah as soon as you
get the settlement you're debt free
You're Gonna Roll through baby step two
baby step three and Rachel's right I
think on that but just you know do you
roll that into it into your own
retirement account on what you already
have I'd love for you to sit with a
smart Master Pro if you if you were my
friend and you are my friend now I'd
want you to get a couple of opinions on
that and just look at the tax
implications and everything but yeah but
that being you know if and if you decide
to cash out that 401k without the
penalty you know that could be a great
baby step 3B of the down payment of what
you're thinking you're making a great
income
um Julie and I think yeah I mean
everything you're saying is is on track
and I would continue to fund your
retirement like you're saying you have a
hundred thousand dollars in there so
you're gonna you have such a great head
start on your own doing that
um but if you hold on the line if you'll
pick a pick up
um because I want to give you Dr John
Delaney's new book it's coming out here
in the next few months called building a
non-anxious life and I think just the
healing portion of this for you in the
marriage and the divorce is important as
well
don't move more Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey show
about your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour we are here for you let's get back
to the phones in Phoenix Arizona Ray is
waiting Ray how can we help
hi there thanks so much for taking my
call you bet
I am on baby step one and I'm struggling
because I don't necessarily know how to
manage that feeling of insecurity I keep
getting of only putting a thousand
dollars in my emergency fund and then
moving on to baby step two oh this is a
really good question yeah so tell us
what you are specifically worried about
because I feel like I heard you say I'd
like to have more than a thousand saved
is that what this is really about is it
exactly how I'm feeling and like I'm
feeling like even when I do get a
thousand in it
um I'm not gonna have my budget where
it's cut out where I'm spending every
single dollar every month
um I just I'm scared something will come
up in a thousand dollars isn't enough to
cover okay so we'll be back in the spot
where I gotta take out debt okay so do
you have margin feels like you've got
margin in your budget right now I do
what kind of margin do you have
uh it's gonna be fluctuating throughout
the year
um but I'd say it's a good chunk once I
start getting rolling on my vet snowball
what was that
what is a good chunk when you say that
what does that mean is that 200 is that
two thousand dollars so it's gonna
fluctuate yeah some months it will be
like 300 some months it can be up to
five thousand okay perfect and how much
debt do you have
sixty five thousand sixty five thousand
what is that debt
uh fifty five thousand student loans
three thousand on personal loans and
then seven thousand on a car loan okay
and how much are you making a year
uh 85 in between 85 and 105 000.
yeah good for you that's great
um so yeah I mean I think part of that
thousand dollar emergency funds
there there is going to be a level of
angst and urgency which makes people go
through the baby steps baby step two
that much faster because they're like oh
my gosh I feel like if something were to
happen but the truth is Right majority
of emergencies that we see uh whether
it's new tires on a car you know
whatever it is most of it is under a
thousand dollars so majority of it is
and if not all you do is you pause the
debt snowball stay current on everything
pile up some cash with what you need
fixed and fix it and so you just having
the idea that there's gonna be no debt
the debt is not an option you find a way
to get through it all you find a way
like you really do so if it's the car
that's breaking down you go and get
three options and you fix the small part
that you can to get truck along to you
save up to fix the rest I mean you just
you figure you figure it out and so the
problem is that debt has just become
such a safety net for people that
mentally you can't even imagine you know
not having the credit card just in case
of an emergency and so that thousand
dollars will cover most of the stuff
that you need and if it doesn't you just
pause pile up some cash and go through
it
and right here's the deal I love how
Rachel explained that because if you
think about that and she's right
factually most of those emergencies are
under a thousand dollars but I got to
the point when I first started this many
many years ago Rachel I didn't want to
touch the emergency fund and my first
step was not to touch the emergency fund
it was to rework the budget yeah totally
okay we paid her four walls but I mean I
would go can I cash flow this without
touching the emergency fund yep and Ray
with the margin you're talking about you
gave us a range of 300 on the low end to
maybe 5 000 because you've got a you
know a little bit different income flow
you're going to be able to be okay and I
remember one time I'll give you one more
story here just to just to drive this
home psychologically I remember it was
early on
and Stacy and I we had no kids and we
bought our first house here in Franklin
and we were on this journey we had
student loan debt there's only debt we
had and so we were working it and going
after and all this stuff and our HVAC
went out and I mean I'm like you got to
be kidding me I'd never been through
this before didn't know what to expect
it freaked me out for a minute and I got
the guy out there and he was like all
right here's it we can do a small fix
and this will get you through
and then I started figuring out okay
what would if I have to buy a new one
you know what how much would that cost
and and by just not freaking out and
realizing I didn't have to pay anything
right now I didn't have to get out of
credit card and go buy a new unit there
was a way to work through it cash flow
it and let's not go backwards and we
never missed a debt payment that we were
paying extra on the loans here's my
point when something like that happens
you can always pause and figure it out
you can talk to the people that you get
the service from hey let me get on a you
know a plan here you know yeah
it's not the end of the world I think
everybody thinks I gotta have that
credit card I gotta have
I mean we get this call a lot when
someone's got let's say they've got
forty thousand dollars rate in their
savings account and they call us up and
they got 38 000 in debt and we go
empty it pay it
Ray you just felt it right there didn't
you
yeah
and so this is a six we give all the
time because most of those emergencies
the point we're making is you can manage
your way through it you can and Ray I
mean a big part of this too is feeling
this intensity of getting out of debt I
mean like that's a huge point we talk
about the behavior change aspect of all
of this and you have to do something
different to get a different result and
you obviously are at a point that you're
not happy with where you are financially
so you want to change your habits you
want to change the way you're looking at
it and the more the faster you attack
this debt and it is gone and it's out of
here which you know you're gonna you
know if you guys buckle down and you
work extra you make some more I mean you
know to be able to get this paid off in
what probably three years uh it there's
something powerful about having this
intensity towards that baby step two
which is really key and so we want that
thousand dollars fast when we tell
people 30 days or less get that sell
stuff do whatever you can get a thousand
dollars and move on because you want
this momentum to start and the more you
kind of like play K okay well we need
like five thousand it's gonna take us
six months to save it up and you know it
just it just drags drags the process on
as your income continues to go to
payments so getting to that baby step
two quickly and going through it as
quickly as possible is really the is
your best bet to Building Wealth from
getting to point A to point B
getting your income back where it's
yours is one of the biggest things you
can do so it's the fastest way and again
Ray you're you're grown you're a
grown-up you can decide you can get off
the call and decide to do what you want
but this has just been proven over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over yep you know what you need Ray
I think Rachel's right you know what you
need you need a big win in the next week
so what's this lowest what's the
smallest debt was it the three thousand
dollar personal loan
one is one thousand left on it and one
is two thousand okay so the debt
snowball you're familiar with this yes
yes all right how quickly could you pay
off that one thousand dollar
chunk
I've budgeted in for September nah
that's that's I appreciate that I said
let's just have some fun here see if we
can get you some momentum what could you
do ray
side something here there sell some
stuff
what could you do to get a thousand
dollars outside of your current income
before end of September what could you
do
uh yeah I mean I I need to sell my
vehicle and I could easily have that
done
no well that's selling the vehicle I'm
not saying we got to jump to that
because that's one of your what's that
vehicle worth
uh I think it'd be I think it's worth
around like 8 000 right now and I've got
7 000 left on it yeah but then you got
then you don't have a car I have another
vehicle that I get it it's a work
vehicle that I can use dude
the Ray of Hope we needed oh I see what
she did there folks well we're doing do
it right do something crazy like sell
the car you'll get a thousand bucks
you'll yeah oh my gosh you'll have to
knock out two debts with that one per
with that one sale what's your car
payment right now on that uh 235 and I'm
paying 150 in Insurance boom you just
gave yourself a raise yeah the car's
gone
the personal is gone you're taking a
little bit out of that student loan and
you're on I mean you're getting there
Ray
you with us yeah it's the heart I
haven't even got through baby step one
though that's the hard part I just need
to do it sell the car and get to baby
step one done
dude rip the Band-Aid off just do it you
gotta just decide it's one of these
things it's gonna feel so good who was I
watching on Instagram it was some some
health guy he's like you oh no no you
know who was it was Tony Robbins talking
about some health guy talking about his
workout or something oh yeah and he's
like
there's no there's no negotiate you just
do it you just can't do it oh you're not
negotiating yeah just just jump in just
do it just do it so Ray
well Tony Robbins cold plunge just do it
jump in the cold water just do it it's
gonna be right by the way I love what
you did there I'm gonna call this
segment word play with Ray I see what
you did there you go you remember
I call you Ray Ray all right folks Ray's
gonna do it it's gonna be fun however
you need to just do it I love it this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Rachel Cruz the
phone number to jump in is triple eight
eight two five five two two five our
scripture of the day comes from second
chronicles 15 7. but as for you be
strong and do not give up for your work
will be rewarded
oh this has got to be a Rachel Cruz
themed quote of the day oh none other
than the whole good ones for me Vera
Wang oh thank you gentlemen how about
that fashion uh when you have a passion
for something then you tend not only to
be better at it but you work harder at
it too that's a kin Rachel combo because
that's my jam that's what I do here at
Ramses I want you to find work that you
really really love have a passion for
because you're going to make that unique
contribution Vera Wang great style would
you say she's more known for her wedding
weddings yeah that's her that sort of
thing that's how I think about her glad
to know that I got that one right I was
a little nervous stepping out there on
the end of the diving board it's a great
fantastic stuff all right let's go to
Fort Worth Texas now Judy is there Judy
how can we help
hello Judy
hi this is
canned Rachel and Rachel yeah
yeah how are you today good I had a good
interview for it's a temp job uh with a
school great
yeah and uh it could lead to such other
jobs so I'm encouraged about good you
know the opportunity way to go Judy
that's a good report that made my
afternoon oh good yeah well my question
is I I have a pension that's just
you know I wanted to know if because I
I'm paying about 1600 a year in interest
on thirteen thousand five hundred of uh
credit card and line of credit debt okay
and you know the interest went up the
you know because of the primary and so
what I'm wondering is if I should take
money out of the pension about half of
it out of attention
um and just you know like take out seven
thousand the first year and 7 000 in the
second year so I don't pay a lot of
taxes and I figured out that the taxes
on it would be
um they're gonna they're gonna send 20
to the IRS but because of the fact that
I don't make that much uh especially
working Camp
um I'm figuring I'd get maybe half of
that back half of the taxes back so
that's my question is is you know to
save on the interest uh should I pay off
that 13 500 uh of the pension in two
years time uh Judy how old are you
uh that's six wow 65 around 65. only
Rachel could ask that question I am 65.
yes all right and how much how much are
you making
well that's the thing I I'm just
currently in a temp job that I'm getting
about 580 a week okay okay
um what would this job pay that you
interviewed for today
uh they didn't discuss salary but it
would probably be comparable because
it's the same number of hours and it
might be a little bit more because of a
Dean's office okay how much is in your
pension
uh Thirty One Thousand okay
um any other retirement that you have in
either savings
uh I have a thousand you know I made the
baby step uh I also have
um
uh 460 for a annuity that I took 10
years ago to get my medical paid for for
life
okay
so you have that cash
and that's it okay because you know my
my goal for you is I want you debt free
and starting to build up more of a
retirement but that is gonna
um
require still you know you working and
bringing that income to knock out this
thirteen thousand so are you living off
the pension right now
I have been for 10 years because I I
took it early to
um get the medical play for okay okay
yeah how much okay with the medical and
how much is coming in to the pension to
you each month
5 40.
440.
440 okay a month is what you're getting
from that yeah yeah I really want to
keep that pension just in place Judy
just for your retirement's sake and and
have you knocking out this thirteen
thousand from this job that you have and
and maybe even being able to work more
hours and doing what you can to get this
thirteen thousand dollars paid off so
that you're not touching that pension
because you want to continue to be able
to have that into retirement
um so that that's my that's my knee jerk
to to yeah well we going to do that is
down the road because this temp job is
going to be nine months and it's going
to be 29 hours a week
okay so I won't be able to I'll just be
able to make some minimum payments for
the next nine months and I've taken the
Microsoft Office uh Suite classes and
I'm almost done with that and so I'm
going to sit for the certification and
then this job has a lot of training that
would enable me to get a better job hey
Judy can I Can I ideate with you can I
throw an idea to you that I want you to
be open to would you be okay with it
sure
I think you're worth a whole lot more
money than you're getting paid and I and
I and I want you to change your mindset
from well I've got to do this temp job
for the next nine months no you don't
that's why it's a temp job you could
leave it tomorrow
and I want you to be thinking about what
I've been reading okay I shared this on
my Show recently Fort Worth Texas is one
of the fastest growing cities in America
you know this yes
Judy Fort Worth Texas is exploding okay
you live in the Greater Dallas area
whatever you want to call it I think you
ought to be thinking about an in-home
Nanny position or something like that
with some wealthy families I my wife and
I about six years ago hired someone your
age to come in and be there when the
kids got home from school she did meal
prep uh light very light cleaning you
know just tidying up laundry stuff that
when Stacy was a working mother outside
of the home it was a massive massive
value to us and she made sure the kids
did the homework and let me tell you
something you just look that up you can
be making really good money uh 30 40 50
an hour potentially because
your gold to a family a young family
that may have two working parents yeah I
want you looking at opportunities like
that what a great environment that is
you know and all of a sudden you're
making really great money in a great
environment what were you doing in your
job
um before Judy before you retired
a university
and I've been an admin assistant since
then at a non-profit company okay
yeah yeah yeah and I'm just yeah the
skills are just thinking outside the box
like what you're saying can because I do
think then but
um not everybody's a good cook I don't
wanna well wait a second don't let me
hang that on you don't let me hang that
you gotta cook the point is could you
take care of kids no
you can't no uh-uh okay all right I'll
leave that one alone
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
but little I didn't even babysit yeah my
daughter has worked on me to try to get
me to get on my granddaughter's level
and it's just that's okay Judy but you
were a mom so you're selling yourself a
little bit short uh but to Rachel's just
thinking outside the box Judy I think is
what we're trying to do because we want
you to because also this pension of 31
you know you can't just live off that I
mean we want more in your retirement to
enjoy retirement than just that as well
so there's gonna be I want you to raise
the level of what work you're looking at
yeah even an executive assistant you've
done it in the non-profit world let's
get you in the for-profit world let's
get you out there where you can make
more money no you're coming at me with
all these but this but that listen Judy
you're 65 you're able and I'm trying to
be kind here you have got to increase
your income right now robbing your
pension to pay off some debt is not a
good move for you
period
and you've got to increase your income
and you can
because you've got to build yourself
some margin that's what I'm getting at
you are worth more than just settling
for a temp job that's giving you 29
hours a week okay that's what I'm trying
and listen I'm I'm trying to cheer you
up and go hey you have got a whole lot
more to offer you're not 95 you're 65.
okay right you got it
yeah I I do all right then get after it
thanks for calling Judy we're for you we
want to see you have a Quality quality
life yeah during these next few years so
oh my goodness great opportunities and
you know here's a quick message for
everybody don't limit yourself keep
looking yeah don't limit yourself Rachel
great great fun today always good to be
with you always can thank you America
for listening yes thank you James Childs
our fearless leader who somehow keeps
the Train on the tracks hey we'll be
back before you know it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here
the show is one of the most popular
podcasts in the world it's your daily
dose of advice on life and money check
out all of our shows from the Ramsay
Network wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
foreign